Francia se encuentra conmocionada
después del Terrible ataque esta mañana
a las 9:45 de un hombre armado de un
cuchillo contra un grupo de personas que
se encontraban a las orillas del lago de
ansí en el sureste de Francia en total
cinco personas resultaron heridas cuatro
niños de menos de tres años que se
encontraban con sus niñeras así como una
persona adulta el adulto y dos de los
niños se encuentran en estado grave el
atacante es un hombre de nacionalidad
Siria que estaba optando al asilo en
Francia pero que también había recibido
ya el asilo en Suecia habla solamente en
inglés y muchas personas hace ya un mes
lo habían visto rondando este parque a
las orillas del Lago dicen que siempre
saludaba con un Bono
el sujeto fue rápidamente detenido pues
había policías que se encontraban
patrullando por el lugar no tiene
antecedentes policiales ni de los
servicios de inteligencia por lo mismo
ahora es la policía de ansi la policía
antiterrorista la que está llevando a
cabo esta investigación Cuando ocurrió
este hecho y se conoció en la asamblea
nacional donde los diputados votaban la
proposición del grupo liot con
referencia a la reforma de la
jubilaciones se respetó Un minuto de
silencio también reaccionó el presidente
Manuel macron que condenó un ataque de
cobardía absoluta en estos momentos la
primera ministra Elizabeth se está
dirigiendo a ancy para enterarse de las
investigaciones y tomar contacto con las
víctimas